ANITA: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW."
ARIZONA HAS A TIGHT RACE FOR
GOVERNOR WITH JUST OVER A WEEK
TO GO IN THE MID-TERMS.
AND KARI LAKE IS NOT HOLDING
PUNCHES AND IS GOING ON THE
OFFENSIVE AGAINST A BIASED
MEDIA.
>> I WORKED IN THE MEDIA IN THIS
TOWN FOR 30 YEARS.
THEY DON'T LIKE CONSERVATIVES,
THEY DON'T LIKE AMERICA FIRST
AGENDAS.
THEY DON'T LIKE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IS BEHIND IT.
BUT IT'S DISTURBING.
THEY WANT THE STATUS QUO.
IT'S DESPICABLE.
I'M TRYING TO WAKE PEOPLE UP IN
THIS COUNTRY AS TO WHAT THE
MEDIA IS ALL ABOUT AND I THINK
I'M HAVING AN EFFECT ON THEM.
ANITA: IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE A
CANDIDATE COMING FROM THE MEDIA
RUNNING AS A REPUBLICAN AND
DOING WELL.
KARI LAKE IS A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
SHE WAS A TOMORROW ANCHOR AT THE
NBC STATION.
THEN SHE WAS THE TOP ANCHOR FOR
22 YEARS AT THE FOX STATION.
SHE IS LEADING IN THE POLLS BY 3
POINTS OVER HER DEMOCRATIC
OPPONENT.
LARA, YOU WORKED ON ANOTHER
MEDIA PLATFORM BEFORE COMING TO
FOX.
LARA: BEING ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE CAMERA FOR 30 YEARS, YOU
KNOW HOW YOU CAN ALTER THE STORY
BY PUTTING IN ONE THING AND TAKE
SOMETHING OUT.
I LOVE HER STRATEGY.
I'M GOING TO PLAY MY FULL
RESPONSE SO PEOPLE GET THE
ENTIRE BACK AND FORTH BECAUSE
THAT MATTERS.
I THINK BACK TO MY FATHER-IN-LAW
WHEN HE WAS IN OFFICE.
SO OFTEN THE MEDIA WAS SO
CALCULATED AND DISHONEST.
THEY WOULD TAKE A TINY BIT OF
WHAT HE SAID.
IF THEY TOOK THE CHARLOTTEVILLE
SOUNDS BITE AND PLAYED THE WHOLE
THING.
ANITA: IT'S AN INTERESTING
TACTIC THAT LARA DESCRIBED.
SHE HAS ANOTHER CAMERA SHOWING
HER ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS.
JOEY: SHE LEARNED IT FROM
SOMEWHERE.
KARI LAKE, RON DeSANTIS,
DONALD TRUMP.
THESE ARE FIRE BRANDS WHO HAVE
NO INTEREST IN PLAYING BY THE
UNSPOKEN RULES OF FAKE CIVILITY.
AND THEY PLAY THEIR VALUES
AGAINST THEM.
THIS IDEA YOU CAN'T SAY WE
SHOULD BE AN UPSTANDING SOCIETY
THAT RESPECTS ONE ANOTHER BUT
YOU CAN'T DROP A FOUR-LETTER
WORD ON THE RALLY STAGE?
THAT KINDS OF NARRATIVE HAS BEEN
DEBUNKED FOR YEARS NOW.
IT'S ABOUT HOW THEY RUN AWAY
FROM IT.
KARI LAKE IS VERY EFFECTIVE.
I DON'T NOPE ALL HER POLICIES,
BUT SHE GETS HIT EVERY DAY BUT
IS VERY EFFECTIVE.
HOW SHE IS CAMPAIGNING, LOOK FOR
MORE OF IT BECAUSE IT'S
EFFECTIVE.
ANITA: HER OPPONENT KATIE HOBBS
WON'T DEBATE HER.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
DAVID: SHE IS UP AGAINST SOMEONE
WHO CAN COUNTER HER.
WE HAVE SMART PHONES.
USE IT NYPD.
THEY USE IT WHEN THEY COVER
RIOTS.
THEY HAVE A CAMERA CREW.
THAT'S HOW THEY HAVE GOTTEN OUT
OF TROUBLE WHEN THEY ARE
ACCUSED.
THESE ARE EFFECTIVE METHODS.
ONE THING CANDIDATES NEED, THEY
NEED MEDIA CONSULTANTS.
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
USE SOCIAL MEDIA, CAMERAS IN
THEIR POCKETS TO PUT IT OUT
THERE FULLY.
STOP RUNNING AWAY.
REPUBLICANS, REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES NEED TO TOMORROW
RUNNING AWAY FROM MEDIA AND RUN
TOWARDS IT AND USE IT AND PUT IT
ALL OUT THERE.
IF YOU WANTED TO HEAR ANYTHING
OR PRETEND DONALD TRUMP DID
ANYTHING.
HE DOESN'T HEIGHT HIDE ANYTHING.
HE TELLS YOU WHAT HE THINKS AND
KEEPS GOING.
LARA: I THINK THAT'S WHY KARI
LAKE HAS BEEN SO EFFECTIVE.
PEOPLE LOVE THAT.
DAVID: HE TOLD YOU EVERYTHING.
LA